[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back the bullet open
championship is gonna be amazing you
know it's gonna be amazing
because i have the best commentator in
the abyss don't tell robert has i'm
joined by
grand master maurice ashley how you
feeling today man i'm feeling good i'm
feeling good
yesterday was so dynamic it was just
incredible watching these bullet players
show their stuff
and now we get to see the best of the
best in prime time
this has got to be awesome incredible
chess we're going to see today
absolutely we got a amazing lineup that
we're going to talk about
right now but first of all let's take a
look at the format because it's going to
be a very interesting format it's going
to be two hours of
non-stop passion bullet fashion for my
end it's going to be
a 12 player bracket will show the
players in a bit each side seated one to
six
uh the time control obviously bulbar is
going to be a countdown maurice
15 minutes ticking down we've discussed
this also yesterday
are players going to approach this are
we going to stall or we're going to do
something
uh let's hope there's a tie break
because i love some deaths
and the winner will go to next year
bullet
chess championship and look at these
prizes
5k a winner walks out with today
that's a nice little cha-ching for a
couple of hours work
to put into the bank account no question
and 2k for second place but nobody wants
no stinking second
these players are in it to win it so it
should be an
absolutely mind-bending day as the moves
are going to just come
fast and furious absolutely and maurice
you know these players you know a lot of
these players
um who do you think is going to take
this one
home in your in your humble opinion do
you have any idea
are you talking about the whole thing oh
yeah
the whole thing i mean i'd be an idiot
to bet against hikaru nakamura i mean
come on this guy is just a bullet king
even with players who are higher rated
than him in bullet because they
live for it they're specialists you know
you got your your
your andrew tangs out there you got your
daniel naraditki's who's certainly going
to give him
a run for the money but there's
something about hikaru
when the pain is on the line
when the money money's on the line when
it's time to really deliver
he just seems to do it every single time
so my bet
especially the way he qualified
yesterday my money is on hikaru
absolutely and he does have a very tough
bracket i would say the left bracket
is uh covered on the right side we've
got heavy haters like icaru nakamura
daniel neriditsky uh federsif artemyev
who
is a blitz and bullet specialist of
jeffrey zhang it's just a
tough place to go through it is indeed
the thing about hikaru is everything to
me depends on how he starts
if he gets through the first player then
he just starts
to just rack up the wins he's a momentum
player if he wins one he wins and he
wins again and he just doesn't stop
he has that killer instinct that you see
time and time again
so it's all about the start i think if a
car gets knocked out it's in the very
first round that he plays after that
it's going to be deadly on whoever he
plays because
he's just such a monster but he's going
to have competition paradiski for
example is certainly
a beast jeffrey zhang is quite strong
and andrew tang like i said
those are going to be the favorites and
of course alireza farouza
when he's on he's dynamic and i'm sure
he has his fans out there saying
maurice don't sleep on the young g he's
going to get it done too
absolutely and let's look at the uh the
pairings right now for the first
bracket that we have going on we got uh
vladimir putin
furthest artemis we're gonna do a little
bit of a prediction with jeffrey shang
versus
la tuan min jose martinez versus michola
bortnick and aryan
arigazi versus brandon jacobson now i
know all these players
except brandon jacobson give me a little
bit of a
of a backstory maurice who is what kind
of player is he
brendan's a young g he played in the u.s
junior championship he's a very
good player uh no question about it up
and coming so when you got the young
juniors
you know that's what they live for the
speed they live for bullet they want to
show
their quickness so don't sleep on him
although i think he's going to have a
hard road to hold
when you look at all those serious
gangsters in the field
i also want to point out it's really
unlucky that the two russians have to
play each other
in the first matchup you know they will
be like oh come on
there's a fix on what's the conspiracy
that was knocked out early
well just the way the numbers go you
can't help it
you know just just the way the math
works so for them i'm sure for to say of
an artemia they've played each other
many times
and we'll be teaming with each other
many times as well well somebody's going
to get
bragging rights a risky is going home
and one's moving on
after this round absolutely when they're
going to the olympiad
2021 they're going to say are the mayor
federic who's going to be the board free
i'm going to say
you can put fertilization board 4
because i own them in bullets so i have
that pass so there's a lot of the line
here by the way
olympia 2022 since 2021 has actually
been cancelled
and we're doing it in moscow in 2022 but
yeah it's going to be
in their home country in their home
capital so
let's see who gets bragging rights today
absolutely and
i want to point out uh the second one
jeffrey shank versus latuan man
obviously jeffrey song is one of the
prodigies when it comes to u.s chess i
think he hit 2700 i'm not sure if he's
still there
uh look for him yes absolutely
entrenched entrenched in 2700 land oh
he's there perfect perfect but maine
however um
during the sec invitational he almost
bit he almost defeated duda
young christopher duda almost lost
to our wonderful i am so he is
definitely
a force to be reckoned with jose
martinez and ward nick i will
take it to bortnick i think gording is
more of a bullet specialist and
i want to see brandon go through you
know i want to see an american clash
in the finals which is going to be
hikaru versus brandon
that's my prediction
[Music]
i mean if you said hikaru versus andrew
tang
then yeah that's the most likely
american match-up
that we're going to see hikara versus
andrew andrew tanks a
beast ebola did you see what he did
yesterday i mean i know you did because
we were calling it losing the not making
it to the finals
uh not making it to today after the
first
tournament and he said you know what
that's it i can't believe i didn't make
it to the top six
i'm gonna eat everybody's lunch in this
second
qualifier and he just went right through
and was number one
so that's why he is already seeded into
the quarterfinals
andrew tang will be a force to be
reckoned with and the matchup you really
want to see
is tang vs alareza that
is going to be something special to
watch i really want to see the favorites
go through to be honest
to watch the top seeds make it would be
incredible and on the
on the other side with ikaru jeffrey
and nareditsky there's going to be an
all-american matchup there for sure
i mean going at least well we say for
sure but almost certainly
we're going to see an american matchup
on that side if ikaru makes it through
uh with jeffrey and naradicki sitting
there pretty
so that should be something uh really
fascinating to watch as well
absolutely and for those who think i
made it to the preliminaries
we got the cash uh i have to be
unfortunate
you don't get any cash just yet it's for
only for getting into the quarterfinals
so andrew tang ferocia daniel and
nakamura already got
nice little 250 you know a nice little
exchange things
but they're gonna go for the semifinals
and they're gonna go for a big
gun so we're waiting for the games to
start everyone's getting settled
everyone's getting ready
uh and i'm just if i may sorry interrupt
but that's a good point you know you win
you win your
your section you come in first or second
and you got a 250 bucks
i mean the people who did it in one
tournament that was for an hour of work
250 an hour that's not a bad rate to
just be sitting around
whipping out chess moves that's pretty
good that's pretty good and if you
make it any further hey kaching a
thousand dollars
for a couple of hours hey that's not
bad loot i think a lot of our fans out
there be like
i'll take that i'll take that and i'll
be saying the same thing
give me that give me that and for
playing chess for playing bullet
are you serious come on now that's
ridiculous that's like
those guys making big dollars playing
video games i mean
it is actually yeah what a life is
really good
yeah you sit back and you make a few
hundred maybe a thousand maybe two maybe
five
and and you're sitting at home and then
you could just go to go hang out later
with your friends
and say yeah i just i got i got the tab
i got it
what did you do this evening i worked
hard and that's the thing you know
i've been i've been watching the u.s
chess champs uh i watched christopher
you unfortunately lose in the finals
against alex
on his birthday on his birthday with a
mouse slip that was uh
that was the rough he was busted he was
busted he was busted already but
you never know it went from minus two to
minus six so that's that is the
thirty but what we did see was uh
the entire thing was 90 minutes plus 30
seconds
people sweat they take four to five
hours
and now they can be done in 10 minutes
and boom
in 15 minutes chad there's a 15 minute
countdown in 15 minutes they can already
earn 250.
we're already through there that is that
is crazy i
really love this format i don't know how
it's gonna work out with the sec
countdown without increments so we're
gonna i'm going to expect a lot of fire
we won't have player camps for the first
round but after this for the
quarterfinals
we get to see the players antagonizing
faces if i can say so
we want to see the emotions you know you
see our faces when a blunder happens
and we go ballistic like what the heck
watch when these players blunder
in critical moments you're going to see
a lot of emotion come out hikaru
normally
pulls quite a few faces i want to see
some of the other players
just just be devastated after a loss and
be exhilarated after
a victory the more passionate chess i
think the better
absolutely you don't really get to see
the passion over the board because
people are tend to like
calm down there are other players in the
room so you can't really freak out
even though it does happen we do have
stories about people freaking out in
chess rooms which i love
uh but if you're you're in the comfort
of your home so you're more inclined to
just
break a mouse well let's not do that but
yeah let's see it
[Laughter]
oops unfortunate i can't continue
because i don't have a
no use the track pad buddy boy you know
this should be really
funny to see something like that but i
would love to see some emotional
uh reaction somebody jump out of a chair
or
like yeah look what i did
they flipped their entire table it just
that that
that that would make uh that that would
definitely uh go viral without any
question about it
so question for you maurice when did you
have the
biggest when were you like the most
exuberant when you won a chess game can
you remember
what's the most like final thing where
you're like that was a great moment
and i really wanted to scream it out or
you did scream it out but you couldn't
my most exhilarating moment ever was
when i made my final gm norm to be
honest that was a big moment i've been
trying for several years
to do it i did it in new york city my
home city
after traveling the world to try to do
it i finally actually did it at home i
defeated
adrian neglescu in round eight of the
tournament the manhattan invitational
and he didn't even know that if i won
the game
i would get my norm my title my final
norm in the title yeah so when i
finished when the game was over he
resigned
the smile on my face lit up the room and
he looked at me and he said he's like
why are you so happy you know right
you just see it like you just won a
chess game why are you so happy
and i said that was my last norm and he
was shocked
and then he's like congratulations and i
remember walking
outside it was march the 14th 1999
walked outside
it was snowing and snow i'm not a snow
fan i'm not a cold fan
but the snow never looked so beautiful
it was like
winter wonderland it was just like snow
it's like it's a magical moment
it wasn't christmas but it was like a
christmas miracle
man it was an amazing moment in my life
never forget that night
you were this close to making a show
snow angel just jumping in there
make a snow ancient just let it all in
no that was
getting gentle boy doesn't do snow
angels but yeah
that was definitely it was a moment to
do it that would have been the moment
absolutely oh that's beautiful i can't
really so
that's the thing i can't really say it
because i haven't really achieved that
much in chess just yet but
we're gonna get there uh my favorite
moment in that was i was playing a 2250
over the board
and so i was at the moment i didn't have
a feeder rating so i was like you know
this guy he's nothing and he was having
a very complex position he was like
positioning everything he was always
like rubbing his hands
you know cracking his neck he was
feeling really good and then he made a
move where he thought he had me
and he was ready to get up at that exact
moment
i made like an intermesso hit the clock
and i got up and he was like
oh you gotta love those yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i didn't do but i was close i was close
parents
uh that's right the game now sit down
exactly be humble
the games have started so let's see all
right let's go let's go
and we got jose martinez on the board
right now
against bortnick and we're going to
watch the clocks
ending pause any pause is going to be an
important moment and you see the players
just blitzing out all the opening moves
right now white has a little bit of
space but black has broken with e5 and
certainly
looks like he's equalized the game for
the active pieces
absolutely but you know these open files
work on d1 rook and e1
i think white does have a very nice
small edge if it's actually gets the
bishop to c4
get this knight here get this bishop off
there is a pin you know there are
a lot of crazy ideas easier to play for
whites maybe so i think the problem for
black is where
exactly to put all the pieces right so
that
to me is is the biggest challenge but
then again black is
so centralized that i just don't feel as
though it's
that much trouble b5 a big break a big
break
weakening his own position in order to
get that break that c5 pawn could become
weak
long term and i think though the problem
is you might need a tricky solution
maybe bishop takes
on c3 was the right way to play but he
didn't have time to look at it so
he's just blitzing out the moves now
this exchange
white is for choice with the pawn on d6
this is gonna be problematic and what's
this b5 that's just
that looked like a gift of a pawn but he
didn't take it i'm not sure
what was going on there and now he's
taking it what was the problem before
there was no problem before white is up
a clear passport
now the question is can he break the
blockaders bishop
f1 to avoid all tricks right now he's
just trying to
make sure there are no tricks because he
hasn't seen the solution yet i would
have put a bishop on c7
seconds a long time ago only 10 seconds
left against 15 seconds there is not a
lot of time left he's trying to exchange
the queens which will happen
this pawn is not going to fall with
bishop yeah bishop b5 by the way would
have been an interesting line and now
both of them are just blitzing out moves
they're under 10 seconds
a nice check wins and now white is up a
piece but can he win
as they're blitzing down with only
seconds left you're gonna move man
you gotta move you gotta move all they
can do is just make moves bishop makes
three wins a rook he's gonna take in the
room
you're gonna take it for free he missed
it
is back in business oh black lost on
time
wow that's what we're going to see a lot
of today folks
heart palpitations that was just game
one that was just
part of palpitations there were so many
missed moves there absolutely and
we see this game we switch over to
brandon jacobson a much more
right position your black is up upon
legs and pawn has centralized pieces
this should be
a draw with perfect play i would almost
say but this is bullets there's not
going to be a draw here maurice
i don't think there's going to be a draw
with 38 seconds left for black as black
is saying i'm up a pawn
i'm going to torture you i got a rook
sitting on a beautiful square your rook
is passive
i'm going to be able to bring my king up
as well i would play e i was about to
say
i play e4 drop the rook on e3 and
pick off the pawn well now he can do it
rookie three take a pawn
and this position is just dominant for
black oh my goodness king e3 looks great
because king e3 and f3 would have been
absolutely
flavorful but look at those weak pawns
that white has he's desperate
he's desperate black with 25 seconds and
bullet that's a year
absolutely no he's got to hide behind
the pawns but that shouldn't be
that shooting probably there are no
checks he's got four of them back the
rook up and just start pushing baby
the rook is dead just keep pushing pawns
just keep pushing
easy peasy uh this you gotta move the
rook behind
another pawn and oh he he played that
wrong
he didn't have to play that discovery
but he was true
that he did win are we going to see the
scores updated because we're not seeing
an update and
i was just just about to mention that
let me make sure
that they are getting updated there we
go we see aryan getting up 2-0 against
bret and jacobson
uh but let's let's take a look at the
rushing clash
uh what's going on right now vladimir
furthest fader cf
hard to tell this position is certainly
uh a challenging one it looks just about
a little bit better for black because of
his activity but
white has a pawn oh wait a minute that
that a pawn
is oh he's gonna run he completely
overlooked the apon
and now he's in big trouble just trying
to check oh
he hung me
what a steal are timmy and stole that
one
let me go back to the real quick look at
that
oh my god and he didn't yeah he could
have
that's right he just walked he literally
walked into it
this is what happened he walked into it
and set up his own mate
suicide he should have backed his king
up one
one quick check and then get well then
you still lose the queen
you just one big back run away but that
that's bullets for you
that's crazy let's go back to d he made
that position but for a draw but he
didn't see the mate at all he just hung
the mate
absolutely do you think he saw the mate
it was just a lucky one
and jeffrey john lost he went up 1-0 and
then lost
and and by the way jose martinez came
back with a win only one matchup so far
with a big lead is the one
with brandon uh losing right now to
arjun so that one
he's got us he's got to win it gotta
quickly try to win
this position looks dominant for black
right now black is just for choice big
time he's gonna grab the stuff
and he has like you said a year ago
and this is the problem the when he hung
mate we we have this saying
i remember vinnie livermore in
washington square park one of the great
hustlers
of all time uh he was featured in the
movie searching for bobby fischer
and vinnie livermore after you blundered
like that
in a game he would say one is good for
two
one is good for two it means you you
lost one game it means you're gonna lose
another one
because you just blundered so badly
right now it's the technique is not
really perfect
what i'm looking at as far as black's
concern but he
is up a piece for the moment he's trying
to organize his forces properly
and not let this eep on white's hope of
all hope push this epon
down the board but it's not looking
great as far as the technical side is
for black at the moment i don't know i
don't know it's really easy to play for
white because the king is completely cut
off you can always throw in a quick
check a quick jab like you said
uh and just run around with the king
this king could go all the way to f5
really easy this should be
i'm gonna call as a win for white it's
easier to play for white well the bigger
point is the time eight seconds left
seven seconds
none this is now an issue black can't
figure out the perfect
coordination for his pieces the king is
hiding well
but he can't figure out how to use the
pieces he's got to coordinate and
they're just going down at three seconds
five seconds and oh he goes
he had ample opportunity there and
instead
didn't handle it well in the time
pressure that was a big
big win for fedex a big win it was just
the fact that the king was cut off it's
easier to give checks you can run away
but it's we're already halfway there the
time is flying let's look at a bridge
generation down 3-0 let's look let's
keep on this game and then move on to
the other one
um pretty yeah this this matchup is
going to go back and forth
they may be friends i don't know if
they're friends and buddies
but hey this is the championship they're
playing for and that pawn on c4 is under
heavy fire right now how to defend it f4
f6
that's a bold move saying i want your
pawn give it to me
there's a nasty looking pin but he
couldn't take advantage of it
and now i don't know why rook c don't
queen b3 that's the problem queen b3
what look how he's handling his business
i would move my king at some point just
off the line if i were black just to get
the king out of there
because that that attack on the king
side is starting to get a little
bothersome
all right the other king just moved but
here's that five and
white oh that's a big one i just didn't
like this
and then it happened and suddenly black
has to give a pause on the position look
how long he's taking
in a bullet game he sacked the exchange
but this is
terrible this is stuck awful awful no i
agree if
the rook is going to swing over it's
likely giving more room maybe even rook
to d6 we can get a date that maybe it
was necessary to get it
decided to trade queens give up the
exchange in this position
but this looks awful check and now pawn
on e7 you've got to go
stop it king of seven is forced and now
the knight is trapped
isn't the knight trapped he could just
win it rook you're correct
this doesn't care doesn't matter he's
carried out he let the knight dance out
into the game and his rook
is hanging and now a check and black is
fighting white might be winning
but black is creating counter play it
should be easier to play for black once
he gets e7 pawn there should be a lot of
checks that like you said the knights
are very tricky make sure they put your
knight
two points right he trades everything
off and this shirt it's only a drawer
and now it's only a draw oh he blundered
opposition can he pull it off can he
pull it off should have enough time
let's see the technique
and he just needs to bring his queen
back now bring his king up and that's
all she's going to be right
but let's see what's going on five no
stalemate that's the only problem but
two seconds left
this is ample time queen what are you
doing what are you waiting on queen
e2 you want it you want it it's fine you
went for the checks it didn't go for the
match
you're right you're right there's no
time there's no time palpitations
man um okay jose martinez against
bortnick the store is now
three one for boarding he's definitely a
hybrid favorite
with only five minutes left with brandon
jacobson
he's down five oh your prediction
remind me never to take your stock picks
never because you said brandon might
make it an all-american final
oh he you know that's the thing when you
start losing games in bullet
your confidence goes down and you could
just lose every single game and that's
what's happening
he's not this bad he got here for a
reason but when you start losing games
the tilt factor comes in and to overcome
tilt is extremely difficult so
poor brandon right now down five nothing
but in the meantime we have
a more competitive matchup here jose
needs to win this game oh right before
rook g4 would have been made
in the mix would have been a cool one
i'm not gonna look at it okay rocket
four finally get the g pawn
there he goes it's easier to play for
black i would say because he had all
these checks 17 seconds against 13
seconds
like white's a pawn though whoa whoa
that's a decision
there why do you give away his a pawn i
don't know you should have doubled rooks
bad news and now you're just blitzing it
out 11 seconds for white he's trying to
make sure that he doesn't lose
some kind of technical way oh no oh
he dropped a rook beautiful play by
black trying to avoid
and now the question can't trade rooks
he's got to keep playing now there is a
tragedy
black mate with that much time on the
clock the answer is yes too much time
you're going to get married easily here
it comes over
and then that's that's amazing no
problem checkmate with the two rooks
beautiful technique i actually i want to
really mention that
he well never mind uh actually i will
really mention really quick he just had
like
a very subtle in this position he just
moved his rook to f7 i'm gonna say
i'm safe now i'm gonna use this rook to
harass your king and start moving my
palm
that was like the momentum very good
technique in that position
uh let's look at brandon let's give him
some let's give some fight left let's
see if we can get
one win on the camera but oh it's six
oh i mean it's the pain
and also being broadcast as well that's
the worst part
and you know people like you are like
let's give him some love he's thinking
no don't show up in this game please
what are you
this is doing 6-0 you can't win a single
game
i mean oh my goodness this is full-scale
tilt
on the junior right now and his position
as
black he's looking for some play but
he's down a pawn and it's
two-pack well it's one passer and that
eight pawn is
flying up the board he just took that
that looked like
uh potential sacrifices there but now
he's at least one upon back but he's in
a wicked end game
he had to give up a piece and he's
hoping to disrupt white's pawns
on the king side but that knight needs
to get back in the game somehow i'm not
really sure how though the knight
is not well 98 wow nice move
and he just took the pawn but there is
some play for black there is absolutely
can he make it problematic and oh g5
that's a cute move ouch look at the h
pawn run
and h6 is going h6 h7
h8 okay rook here oh my god
and now it's just bringing the knife
back he's already cut off and
that's it that's all she wrote eight
seven oh
argents 1 minute and 30 seconds left
let's go to jeffrey shang versus little
one they're 4-4 right now
all the other games are pretty much the
side except the russian clash let's see
how this one's going to turn out that's
probably not decided and bortnick
definitely going to win that match up
but right now jeffrey needs
to make sure he wins otherwise he's out
white needs to win this game and he's
dominating right now
oh it is tight they are tied right now
so a draw is fine to go through some
death
well therefore 59 seconds left um if he
wants to avoid the sudden that you're
talking about yeah
and by the way knight e2 and now he's
one upon has has black he's up upon
but that d-pawn is so strong but what's
the conversion what's this
yes 28 and the knight
is on the d8 square that's a lot that's
a hard piece to lift queen of six what
did he do this for he just gave away a
piece
wait hey six yeah
the knight was hanging and now he just
needs to promote white is clearly
winning
jeffrey has always go for f2 oh it
doesn't matter bishop g2 it's fine
it's easy this is easy this is there he
goes now he just has to stall
he just has to stall now let's quickly
look to the oh he
he still has to he still has to not lose
the game does jeffrey right
because a new game the game does count
you're correct they're correct the game
counts
and and a draw in that matchup with only
four seconds
oh and they still got a game oh demian
would have won the match if he could
have kept it going
but has a chance because there was four
seconds left and they started
again the match with arjun is over
brandon lost seven
oh uh bortnick won five and a half so
that's done
jeffrey's still in the middle of his
game so two games on fire right now
and we're seeing the russians who goes
through artemia with the edge he's got
the white pieces
a draw is enough but he should know
don't play for a draw when you need a
draw
play for a win and let the other player
beg for the draw so we'll see if he can
pull it off with the white pieces right
now
absolutely and also enough obviously
another important match is going on is
jeffrey shang versus
le toimen he needs to win wonderful time
needs to win so we're also going to keep
an eye on that but mainly on this game
let's see how this is going off
uh right now we don't want to switch too
much with white having a
small edge on the queen side but
not too much i don't know you call it
small by the way bishop b5 there was
crushing
after c5 he missed a winning move on the
spot
did artemyev but now
president won the game a beautiful
position
uh again that bishop b5 was calling
itself but look at that last move
the pieces are so dominant he's not sure
what to do though with the white pieces
here
the the technique is escaping him his
bishop on c3 is the problem
his bishop has no real future so he's
trying to figure it out isn't this
false i was about to say wasn't that
hanging rook to
he wins a clean pawn this is desperation
this is all over
this is all over people bishop takes and
now
he's trying to defend he's trying to
defend but there goes another pawn
biting the dust
and the oh he doesn't have enough on the
draw he needs to win all he's got is a
draw a draw is all
that white knees white doesn't care you
can check him all day long he's got 19
seconds on the clock
black could not take it for pet and here
he goes he could just
why is he trying to mate just check just
check him
just check him why did he do that i
don't know
he just needed a draw he kept the game
alive
oh we always bloated this what are you
doing with
all the time on the clock he's lucky
he's still drawing he's lucky
oh my god dude oh my goodness that was
crazy
wonderful time one so we have what
happened here just really
lost yeah we're down to a sudden death
absolutely and special shout outs
well it's quick special shout out to
brandon jacobs who did get a win
so it wasn't a quick edo
i don't know exactly the rules of sudden
death uh so let me ask my team
uh real quick to see what's going on we
will go into a sudden death uh aryan
congratulations
we have boardnick going through and we
have
uh artemyev going through a set of uh
phantom savers a bit of an upset on my
end
uh very well played and we're going to
see some death between jeffrey zhang
and just a wonderful time amazing
uh yes indeed jeffrey blew that
jeffrey brew that big took it over the
game but we have time
big time he blew that one he was just
well what can you say what can you say
you just all you need to do is draw the
game
and you end up losing uh
not good that's a bad opening for wife
this is a bad very bad opening for white
i mean look at this nasty position he's
down a pawn his pieces were back okay
burst off because here it is
really easy the first person to win
moves on it's that easy they can play a
hundred games
doesn't matter bullet qualifier bullet
man tiebreaks are the best
and here we go blackish black has got a
bad bishop on c8
and we'll hope to somehow get that going
at some point why it will castle quickly
and why will a for some key square c5
looks like a nice square
for something to go to if a knife only
could get a knight to migrate
and i like what black is doing to be
able to play for the move bishop
to a6 but he just hung up on boom let me
snatch that one off
so he's down right now that's a good
start
we could go in and jeffrey
this is over jeffrey is showing why he's
and a brilliant bullet player as well
and now
black is just desperate oh a knight mate
threat
have seven don't touch my knight look at
these knights
dominant there's no way to survive he'd
sack this queen
and this is going to be all over but the
crying
35 seconds left for jeffrey he just
needs to play
the right move why did he give away an
exchange there i have no idea
that wasn't necessary but he's just
going to keep trading pieces let's trade
it down
he's got a fast h pawn and he's going to
just push it and he's going
he's just going to go keep going keep
going forward it should be
this should be an easy win for white uh
he also is ten seconds up of the cup
actually jeffrey's underrated queen b6
is boss
queen b6 is nasty actually again look at
that bishop it's
devastating that bishop is going with
check and he's got 21 seconds
this he can slow play this he can slow
play this one
there's no pass going for black that's
the worst part black has no counter play
anywhere bishop a4 now
bishop a4 is coming bishop a4 at some
point he's going to move his king away
and again check and he's played bishop
e2 but he could play bishop a4 and the
guy would have cried he's trying to go
forward
but this is dead deadly too
yeah that's back what a mate that's wow
game over jeffrey sneaks through at the
end
wow wow congratulations jeffrey
what a game uh congrats like i said
artemis
goes on to the next one i think the
bracket is
updated it is updated let's show that
real quick
we have hikaru nakamura versus vladislav
art of af
jeffrey shang versus daniel naraditsky
that's going to be an american clash
andrew tang versus bordnick and aryan
aragassi versus
aleurasia ferocia it's gonna be a
rough game for everyone good at
competitions
may i ask arjun is from which country
erika
he's from india okay so we got india the
ukraine we've got russia
we've got the u.s u.s well represented
on both side of the bro
wait a second are we saying that a lot
of american players are superficial
because they just like bullet because
i see four americans playing right here
in this bracket half the field
as americans and then one of each
country well alareza
right now looks undecided at the moment
as he
he's playing under the fide flag i
believe
wow these are gonna be
big boss match-ups do you see the
players
right now who are playing this is going
to be
fierce bullet at its highest
level will be played and whoever wins
this
can say they did something because this
is going to be awesome it's going to be
a great
great quarterfinals we're gonna set
everything from everyone we will be back
in about
six to eight minutes and we will show
you the quarterfinals
the board open chess championship see
you guys
just a bit
[Music]
so
and welcome back ladies and gentlemen
the bullets open championship
with a man maurice ashley maurice
exciting games
going well i'm glad we had that break
because
my heart rate was going so quick i might
have to take medication
to calm down it was just so exciting
so exhilarating just heart pounding
action and it's just going to get better
now as
a few of the gangsters in bullet chess
have
come into the play and this should just
be
on as the best of the best have joined
us
i mean it's just amazing absolutely and
you're mentioning gangster
and what i also know is that you do
something on your twitch channel
gangster chess what is that exactly
rules
gangsta chest just means that you go for
blood we don't want to see
technical end games there's no kappa
blanca niceties
karpov precision play petrosian defense
no no we only want to see people get
pounded we say
hit him hard boom hit him again that's
the kind of games we go over
in gangster chess and there's no way in
the world you're not going to come away
feeling like okay i'm ready to beat all
my friends after watching
that kind of play absolutely you got to
get hyped exhilarated as you mentioned
beforehand
we are no second grade diligence when it
comes to chess and we will get gangster
on you so make sure
to show about twitch.tv slash gm
ashley's where you can find them i
believe monday wednesdays and
fridays are set yes indeed those are the
three days i might come on other days
depending
but those are the days that i'll be on
regularly perfect man perfect make sure
to follow
him we have chescom chris in the chat
you know chess come chris he's a beast
shouting you out i'm also streaming
twitch tv slash bigfoot
well it's all about maurice today but
it's not actually all modern recently
forget maurice it's about the players
let's look at the price really quick
we got gangsters here the bullet
gangsters and look at these brackets oh
my goodness
these are just nasty brackets you could
you could just
call these you know in many places
especially our temmie of nakamura
i'm going to tell you that one's just
sparkling in my eyes it's like
whoa we got to watch that a little bit
extra we want to give everybody love
but that one we're going to have to give
a little bit extra love because those
two
are some serious oh geez well we got a
young g in there
as well as our temmie if not so old but
that's going to be a fun
matchup to watch absolutely we can
actually look at them right now
the car streaming at the moment as well
he's calm he's cool collected with a 2k
cab i could see the pimples on his face
look at that oh he's he's a little
nervous you see that
doing a little shuffle carver man this
guy is absolutely amazing his ability
to play quickly and talk he might be
able to even type messages
while he's playing and talking and
drinking some
some uh red bull i guess red bull is
still a sponsor
of his the guys just got some
some i i can't do it you know i
multitasking
god is ikaru nakamura absolutely and
not only he's playing we have some other
huge players as well
uh that we're gonna go for for let's
look at the prices real quick we have
some huge prizes
as well first place 5k going for the
open second place
2k just replacing second just for a few
games
it is amazing uh and there are still
some players joining chat so we gotta
keep our cool we gotta calm down the
players joining and
we'll be starting very soon keep our
cool and calm down what are you talking
about
this is the bullet open championship
they would fire us if we kept our cool
and calm down can you imagine trying to
do a golf call
while this is going on no not going to
happen we're going to
keep it busy keep it live keep it
flavorful because the players are going
to move faster than we can talk
let's just be clear they're going to be
flying through the moves
and we got to try to keep up with them
you're right you're right you know how
they urge it oh they're right listen
you're trying to write the chat i can't
handle the chat when they write
they become figures monsters um but we
do have
all the players in the cams right now so
it should
be going well i'm gonna
fire up the players here
and i see 1k for the semifinal as well
so everybody's got their 250.
that's okay that's all right but another
750 dollars
for 15 minutes of play let's be real
that's like 15 minutes 750 every 15
minutes
boy you might be getting like jeff bezos
money if you could do
that i think he might be making
i think he's making more than 750 every
15 minutes
that guy but still that's a nice chunk
of change
to add with some quick bullet skills you
know when these guys were playing bullet
back in the day when
carl was playing bullet chest as a young
man i'm talking about
when he was 10 11 12 years old could he
have imagined
that those skills that we were just poo
pooing back in the day
no that's not bullet what are you doing
you're just wasting your time all day
can could he have imagined that one day
in the in 2020 that he would be getting
paid kaching for what he just did
for fun just extraordinary the way the
game has evolved and having all these
fans watching
and having fun just enjoying the
greatness
of these players as well yeah absolutely
i mean
i would have never imagined the the
twitch explosion obviously the chess
explosion of these days
do give these formats a chance and they
are off
by the facts actually let's look at
tikaru right now against artemis
let's see uh how he's doing over here
yes indeed we missed some of the opening
right here but it's all right because
it looks as though white is trying to do
some damage
on the queen side the move a6 will come
at some point
to make that b-pawn work but black just
played an amazing knight c5
and won an exchange but the white knight
on c5
maybe hikaru intentionally dropped the
exchange i mean this is this isn't
karu's
skill somehow you know yeah it looks
like
i was making a mistake but no oh no did
he just blunder a mate
did he actually getting his one boy and
he's in big
trouble because that king is under a
heavy attack
he just played check but he could not
take the rook it looks like he's going
to get
mated and this check that's
that's only a draw now that last move
art i don't i don't like it oh no he's
blunder to me
he's walked into it his king is in deep
trouble
and he knows it this but but i'm not
sure
yes there it is there it is he's just
dropped this queen
no but he look at this what's going on
is this real is this real he got his
queen back he got his queen back
it's insane he's winning now how does
hikaru do this this is unbelievable
he actually won a game that he was
getting mated and artemy went for the
queen instead of mating
and ikaru pulled it off i i can't
believe what i just saw
that is nice i literally cannot believe
what i just that's not fair
it's just not fair how does he do that
he was i saw the bar going up and down
left and right it was
jumping at me from the screen but i
don't even time to look at that game
let's look at this game what is
happening on the h file
uh i think artemis cannot believe he
just lost the game he just lost
and he is in big trouble it's not about
the age file
it's about the psychology of the moment
right now he's in big trouble for losing
the game he just lost to hikaru when he
was
mating that king i'm sure there was a
mate in there somewhere
and he blew it and now
he's got to somehow get his head wrapped
tight because if he lets hikaru win
another game we know how
the the guy works he'll win every game
game after game after game he just he'll
just punish you
and that's what he's facing right now
psychologically
is artemy event all of them in the world
know it including magnus
that when you're playing antsy karu look
at this e4 hitting the queen
if you play knight d4 c5 is coming
i mean this is just awful this is just
awful c5
gift me the piece hello that's it
give me the piece just take it just take
it that's a piece that's it
no problem everybody's connected queen
bishop brook everybody's connected
and black's winning that game hicarro
already up two-nothing
by the way jeffrey has taken a 2-0 lead
in
his match-up against naraditsky that's a
big deal
that is a big deal already
wait can you turn off the moon only
actually absolutely yeah
actually winning again against mikula
boarding they stayed on this game for a
little while honestly andrew 10
congratulations
with your uh signature to
cloud9 now even esports like this it is
amazing and
he's playing some fantastic bullets you
can ask them if it's allowed but i don't
see why it shouldn't be allowed
anyways i'm not going to read shot
during the games
i will have self-control
okay g3 i want to play g5 and fork him
but first let's not let him take the
knight
maybe knight h5
actually let's just trade
i'm not sure about this
at least it should be fine
i'll just trade off the rick or not
this rook is very close to getting
trapped though
not totally sure what i'm doing here
yeah bonds are rushing white is doing oh
but bishop c6 kind of locks it out
beautiful light square bishop taking
everything he's going to keep that on
and
9 seconds against 50 seconds this could
be black screen
i'm playing way too slowly
that's way too much hesitation
it is going to be over and while we look
at this game let's look at the other
game as well
talent that we have going on here is ali
raider surfer russia
against aryan erigasi and
rio um i'm not surprised maurice he is a
beast
hmm
to come back yeah perfect no you're
absolutely correct
it's gonna be monumentally hard to come
back in here but aryan
does have some time left seven minutes
on the clock so it is possible
but he needs to win this one he does
need
to win and right now he's he's
not looking good here and after knight
takes on that four knight e2 check
oh sorry i thought it was a check but
instead it's really just a loss of an
exchange
and now trading down is alireza
and showing his technique here there is
no chance for white
zero zilch he's out four zero
we could we can chalk this match up
almost a hundred percent
to alareza i didn't see an update in the
score there i thought it was going to go
to 4-0
but it is now yeah and that's that and
hikaru
also up four zero momentum just we
walked
we look at jeffrey shaking
you see him shaking his head you see him
shaking he said there
what did i say momentum momentum
momentum
daniel has won four in a row if my count
is correct because i remember jeffrey
being up 2-0
and this was getting worse and worse
that match
is looking really bad meantime we have
two matches that are basically over
ikaru and alareza should go through
which which is going to be great for
the fans i think the only
match up that is really actually all of
them are really powerful right now
andrew tang
daniel naraditsky up two games they just
have to keep their cool
can jeffrey keep his cool right now
yeah absolutely is he gonna keep school
this is a very important game he is
oh no forget about keeping your pool
he's blundering
every single game now every single game
and it looks like this one is going to
be over
plus three will be impossible to come
back from
with only six minutes left on the clock
six minutes is three games
right there's no increment six minutes
is three games
so all narrative gets to do is draw what
all he has to do
draw one of the next games we're going
to count down
a draw wins it ikaru it's over
let's have a quick look and won a game
bortnick won a game
and he is inspect that is indeed
a contestable match let's look at that
game i
i think that is what we should be
looking at let's jump over to andrew
thing
and board nick there we go we have
entertainment
only sequence and andrew not enough of a
lead to be safe
and here bortnik just played a nice
night move and then backed up
i don't understand why and now putting
the knight back on what
square it really belongs on absolutely
this is my last move by the bishop
that bishop is such a woeful piece you
don't even touch it
like you do whatever you like with it
i'm not going to bother it i'm just
going to figure out a plan
in this position it looks like e6 was a
good move earlier when the bishop was
wayward but now the bishop is going to
sit exactly
where it is and white can't figure out
what to do despite having 24 seconds on
his clock
now e6 there you go there we go that was
the breakup you got
a boss position with an f5 move you
can't touch that
and then now the rook to the h-bot if he
can get it there he needs a rook to get
to the h-file
somehow black saw it coming and forced
him to go over
the knight having to drop back i don't
like that what is happening 54.
you got to watch for d4 but now the pawn
is dropping and white still has
great play here nice technique kappa
blanca esque
technique with that a3 move by the way i
like putting everything on dark squares
but is he winning why no he's gonna lose
a piece
of peace oh no my goodness he just
blundered the piece
and the pawn is going through andrews he
played
keep playing tenacious defense that was
awful
why is he resigned there it's four
seconds against four seconds you gotta
have to try there
that was heartbreaking that's the end of
the match that's the end of the match
that game
costing it's over it's over meantime
both
ikaru and alareza have their opponents
on full tilt 5-0
in that match uh daniel just won his
game against
is that six in a row he won against
jeffrey brown
that's over rover the only matchup that
matters is this one
andrew just needs we don't need to watch
these these are
these are bloody every there's there's
bleeding going on we don't want it to
work says no this is the one that
matters
i think competitive as andrew tang needs
a draw
only to guarantee the win so let's see
this game
draw by what oh yeah yeah i think
i mean look at those knights look at the
rooks on the file this is
horrible this is just terrible
completely for black to have to play and
especially when you need a win
can he get a lead on the clock he
doesn't even have that
he could have taken it i think it was
just a uh
a little jab it doesn't matter it's like
it doesn't matter
it's all white needs white has
definitely
not played this well i will say that
white has not played as well
to this point white has given black too
many chances why do you trade queens
though
that's an odd thing to do in this one
what's the last thing yeah that wasn't a
chance on beat three but he doesn't
he got nothing he got nothing zero zilch
soccer fair it's an equal position and
equal positions
tend to be flag fest he just needs to
play fest
if he wins this game he still has an
opportunity but he needs to win this
game
or else it's going to go out of his
hands all right i like what he's doing
on the king side although i would have
rather to have a pawn on h4
than this structure but what is what a
bold player andrew is
to put his king in this position and now
it's all about the past pawn the black's
pawn is very strong but he just
made the king of the board there's no
way to bring the king back
uh in time the black king white pawn
will queen this is a draw now it's a win
for white technical win destroys all he
needs
so he just took the rook and ended it
now not enough time
if he just lasts a couple of
well if there is enough time if he wins
this one
he just has to not hang mate exactly
that's it just not hang mate
quickly uh so you're right if he wins
this game
quickly he has to win it quickly there's
no way it's going to happen four minutes
with him no i don't think it's going to
happen but
i do like myself a uh the possibility
for sound death let's see how it's going
to go out daniel there at 61.
eighth in a row is now the what a beast
eleration ferocious
seven wins uh andrew tang is the only
one that matters at the moment for the
standing so let's see
how that's going to work out knight to
b3 it's not something you'd like to see
with white
no it's not and that lets us trade off
all the buttons
and uh that's going to be all she wrote
in this position i like the dark square
bishop but i don't like losing pawns
bleeding pawns
and being down in exchange i mean is
there a trick somewhere
he wants to get on the h5 you see that
sneaky he's trying to get on the h prop
of the bishop on d4
but it it's not up that not quite
working out
he's trying to stay busy he's trying to
keep it busy but look at this he just
took the c3 pawn
and now he just took the e3 take
it back oh my god
any chance that's it that's awesome a
win
and it's over we have our four
semi-finalists yeah
oh yeah they're going to play a last
game but just to point out real quick
chat
is in this position you can't even take
because you're going to lose this rook
with check so this one was all
over and there's only nine seconds left
let's let's look at
let's have a quick look at daniel
naraditsky let's see how he's been
faring at the end of it it does seem
like there's the ching ching i'm not
sure if you guys can hear that but
this should be a win whoa he gave away
his bishop for no reason and then he
gave away his room
oh my god i mean when it rains it pours
he won a bishop and then instantly he
gave back a rook
that's when your brain stops working
that that's just
he was on such full tilt playing a game
all right it's going to be aborted
uh that's over eight two dominant match
they won by six alareza had the most
dominant result
winning by seven and while at least his
opponent has a chance to
to come maybe not maybe win this game
with i hope he draws
at least but this one he's losing i mean
he's just losing
oh oh we might slip the frog
he might win games and
and no he did not sorry i was wrong it
was the other way around
and it was 8-0 so so actually i was
thinking that it was
the other color but it just was too much
it's so basic
ali raza up 8-0 and that's the most
dominant result
kairu plus six naradiski has made it to
plus seven
and andrew tang has gone through so
we're just playing right now guys we
don't even have to look at the rest
these games don't mean anything at all
absolutely we can see who's going to
move forward who's gonna claim
a nice little uh nice little
uh yeah how do you say that a nice
little payday that we got going on here
for the quieter finals they're going
to move on g i mean you pick up a grand
uh we're playing some bullet 15 minutes
that's always nice yeah this doesn't uh
it doesn't sound too bad for me two of
you are going to get
a thousand others are at least
guaranteed a thousand
orthogonal going through so we're gonna
have some great they're gonna play this
one out chat
doesn't matter too much because there is
draw
and we've got the standings out there
which was incredibly amazing let's have
a quick
look last time what the standings were
ikaro winning seven to one
daniel oh they're playing an ad on
nicaragua's stream so let's
move back to the prizes uh i don't think
the bracket is updated
just yet so we can't show that for now
but let's see how it is
sorry carl winning will move forward
daniel erdicki so if he carved
versus daniel we will get andrew tang
versus ali raza that's gonna be a huge
semi-final
well three out of four americans in the
semi so one will go
on to the final for sure and
our prediction seems like it's going
it's
looks is looking more and more like
ikaru versus andrew tang
which would be a boss matchup
indeed incredible but it to me right now
actually any finals match up will be
boss
you can just pick them just pick them
anyone you say we're going to have
ali raza play naraditsky that's a boss
matchup
any matchup right now would be a boss
matchup but i think that the favorites
all right akaru and andrew tang to get
through because they are supreme bullet
specialists and even though even though
naradiski i think is even higher rated
than hikaru
in bullet if i'm not mistaken the live
bullet ratings
i think he's actually higher rated but
hikaru i mean it's ikaru but hikaru
knows he has his hands full
right now this is going to be a very
difficult matchup for him
as his detanglers matchup as well so
we're going to see some good stuff
if anything we're going to see some
great stuff as you mentioned so we're
going to hit a quick break we're going
to set everything up and then we'll be
back for the semi-finals
build up with championships see you guys
just a bit
[Music]
so
and we are back ladies and gentlemen we
have the semi-finals in front of us to
go
start in just a minute i'm still here
i'm still that way there you go
see the camera has inverted so i don't
know which way to point but now i know
uh maurice ashley
is still here he's also on twitch twitch
to visualize gm ashley make sure to go
there every gangster chess
puzzles all the other stuff um i'm a big
fan
i'm even a subscriber where where's my
fit patch oris that is what i'm asking
we're working on it we're working on it
we're also working on the emotes i try
to upload the brand new fresh
emotes but twitch is it's a weekend
i don't know what they're doing on the
weekend you think we're working on the
weekend why aren't they working on the
weekend
so that i can be approved so i can put
those emotes up
the subs want to know where are their
emotes so that
and their fit badges as well so that
they can have some fun during the chat
we already have fun
doing the chat talking about all the
stuff as you mentioned
gangster chess trivia puzzles news of
the day
we do it we do it all we do it all on
the show
and have fun doing it but look for the
emotes check me out follow me and
sub if you want to get the hot off the
presses emotes
absolutely now let's focus our attention
back to the brackets finals we have
hikaru nakamura versus daniel nardinski
i mean he car is going to have difficult
against daniel because daniel always
puts up a good fight but
i think he will win eventually andrew
tank versus roja
i cannot predict a winner i don't know
what do you think no no there are no
predictions
no this is going to be on like popcorn
no way in the world these players
they're getting psyched look at ikaru
getting
pumped funny to see dania just
lean back you know like fat joe
lean back he's like i'm just gonna chill
i don't care that i'm playing hikaru
nakamura
i can handle this did i see him actually
even yawn there
come on look at that okay
let me let me watch it let me show you
real quick
all right it's out there incredible
from the young g's like i got this ain't
no
they're both on the west coast right so
what's it's now 11 a.m that's pretty
early for these kind of players
uh you know they like to wake up late so
maybe that's why he's still like trying
to get the
the sleep from out of his eyes we'll see
but
the other two players are definitely in
it right now
absolutely so the games are going to
start in just a bit we'll be
working in there let's look at the uh
qualifier knockout rules again real
quick
can you take the chat through with
maurice what's going on
well you know we had we had the early
brackets we had the early brackets and
then we have
this time controller 15 minute countdown
that's where they're going
right now with 15 minutes we see when
you take a lead
the pressure is on one player goes up
three nothing it's probably over i know
that sounds crazy
but it's probably over a three game lead
is enough
even though it's bullet and it looks as
though we have
started so let's get with that but the
winner of this will get
to qualify for next year's bullet just
championship and a fat
5g as well that's absolutely
well we're not there yet this is still
only the semifinals we'll see who
moves on to the final the finalists are
guaranteed at least
two thousand dollars the winner gets
five thousand and here we see andrew
tang versus farouza
out alareza you know he's he's quick but
andrew telling i'm telling you he's
mercurial i mean he's like
i i s when i watch him play he plays
30 30-second chest to warm up for bullet
i mean i've never seen anybody play
30-second chess before
he plays 30-second chess so he can warm
up for bullets so to him it's like
you give me double the time that's what
are you kidding me that's forever ever
like just as too much and already for
ruger with this queen h4
excursion as stolen apart
boom stolen upon thank you and showing
his skills and still has
30 seconds left on the clock look at
that knight on e5
that knight is a beast that knight will
never be chased
trading off queens locking down the
queen side and now it's time to work on
the king side of the board
and he's just going to play it slow he's
got this technically this is over
everybody going to the dark squares look
at that bishop
it's anemic the bishop is ugly trade off
more and more the more the marion here
comes the king now is the king's turn
i'm going to look for an h6 a g5
and an f4 and chase you back you're
going to go backwards son
oh look at this technique man i think
he's going to have the point
he said that's it let's get out of here
i'm going to lose that game the guy's
just too good
amazing and that's a good gotta talk
about that real quick
that's a really good strategy if you
think there's only 15 minutes if you
think you're going to lose
move over to the next game especially at
the starting fifth because you need to
wreck those wins up
and you cannot draw out losing games
beautiful point
beautiful point he resigned somebody
might say he resigned early
but the guy had so much time in the
clock in the wind was so straightforward
for these
players at this level that it didn't
make sense at all for him to keep
playing
stop the game go on to the next one
you're gonna lose play the odds and
that's exactly what he did that's why
these guys are so good
not just add bullet but at strategy as
well match strategy
and that's what happened there and we
see yet another game where he could
uh be in some trouble andrew tang even
though he's got the two bishops
but the the c file in that pawn
especially on c7
is causing him a world of trouble so
at the moment alareza up 1-0 this is a
crucial game folks a crucial game and
now
again the control of the c5 score but i
like the way black has handled this
because he's pushed wide backwards and
he's
broken the bind he's broken the bind on
the c5 square but he's standing at a
cost
he's done under the cost of the f6
square broke the bind on one side but
now he's seen a breakthrough on the
other and alarisa
how he's playing this is going to be
over rupert
wants an idea in both of them he's like
gm chess you understand what i'm saying
to you
he's playing like he's playing against
magnus and
naca at the high level he wins again
gm chest in bullet it's incredible to
watch
this kind of beautiful display of
technique
by ali raise up two nothing let's see
the other matchup though
right now 100 agree karu is up
one nothing so ikaru doing his thing
in this one actually he's up two nothing
as well
we're seeing we're seeing some great
play
by players at the high level players who
are used to playing
at a high level what i'm seeing right
now is actually
not just bullet ability but also
straight
chest strength these are players who are
much higher rated
from a chess strength standpoint you
might be fast
but i play better chess let me point out
one thing maurice let me point out one
thing what happened last time
when daniel was down 2-0 yes
but you know this but this is the kara
nakamura we're talking about
like what i like to say is chest
strength
does matter although it looks like a
blunder on hikaru's part
it looks like he just blew something
what
yes no what's the move why did he take
on a5 i don't know why he didn't take on
a5
there seemed to be some sacrifices
available he was gonna take it on a5 and
threatened
queen a2 queen 82 and
once again the mistakes are creeping in
this is this was a very good position
for black
but somehow now it looks like hikaru has
played
great defense and i don't understand why
am i blind at 85 look like it was
hanging at some point
now hikaru looks to be in total control
of this position and he just has to get
on his high horse
oh six seconds and okay this is still
a little bit of danger he took it take
it on a2 and he's back in the game is
black black is back in the game
he's getting later there we go we moved
and now it is
wow crazy that was crazy and ikaru's
cussing right now
with what just happened in that game oh
my goodness
crazy chest we're seeing but a two-point
lead
for ikaru with nine minutes left plenty
of time but dania has to start winning
games
he's got to start winning games and i'm
not seeing a move right now what is
happening is it frozen i see the clocks
the clocks are strong oh no no no no
that's that's that is correct
here we go we got them back up all right
yeah because no way they're going to
be sitting on the thing for that long
you're correct there is a little bit of
jerkiness going on
like what's this wow what an interesting
mean sack by hikaru why would you do
that
i mean this looks terrible this that was
my that was maya maurice i
i've been told that i misspelled
nakamura's name so we had to uh where to
fix that real quick we can't have that
on stream of course
but let's go back to nakamura by the way
nakamura's getting toasted here
toasted like absolutely he almost hung
mate in that position in the a pawn
look at that bishop on h8
when do you see nakamura have a bishop
like this oh my god it is time to give
up this game this one is
over oh and he dropped his queen as well
after knight to e7 so uh
is he still playing he's still playing
that is he's using the strategy of
your peculiar playing let the time pass
as much as possible that the guy made
you uh
but because you're up and yeah so just
wasting more time
on the clock he's going to let his time
run out
and dania's laughing like come on man
come on man
come on i want to fight nine already
this ain't right he let his time run all
the way down
because he's got a slight lead putting
more pressure on his opponent to win
games
within the time frame so this game now
daniel's got one back that's cool for
him
he's going to look to see what he can do
to even the match by the way in the
other matchup
andrew tang also won a game to make
this one competitive as well so it's
gonna be a very tight one we're gonna
look at this game
after we watch this game don't wanna hop
too much let's look at this one
right now with nakamura having a very
nice e file
it looks like he does have the position
under control beautiful center
um it's going to be hard for daniel to
put to punch through here
but i don't like why the garbage is that
happen after knight takes
on e5 that the file shut down
shut him down and now all of a sudden
it is wait wait why do you allow ec it's
like a little e6 action why
why would you allow e6 why would you
allow yourself
at the group with the position open and
clean it for a check and that excursion
by your bishop
oops i don't know why you
take your bishop away you got to
understand and keep the game tight you
want to keep the game tight and now he's
dropping in exchange as well
that that was really bad on his part
so move to go after an a pawn and a lot
of the breakthrough with e6 was
was not high level that was really bad
on
dania's part and now he's down two
points yet again two games and he's in
desperate
desperate situation and by the way we're
back to this match it looks like alexa
also won
struck back and he's up two so our
prediction is looking bad right now
hikaru yes but not andrew tang
as well the stronger players are proving
themselves
these are the stronger chess players are
proving that
yeah you might be good in bullet but i
am going to put the weight of my ability
on your neck and make you try to figure
this out what just happened
whoa what happened there there was a
trick there we're going to look at that
it was just a trait of queens but at the
moment white is for choice
white is just taking a piece and now
another piece and now another pawn
and white it looks like trading down and
at the end of it he's
able to pick off a pawn but that seaport
is strong that sea pawn is going down
the board
yeah looks back and now the king will
come up over
and there's no way for the c pawn to
advance here comes the white king so
that's going to be okay this looks like
maximum draw for black but he's worried
about it
about his c pawn as white can't figure
out a way to attack it though why can't
figure out a way to attack
it if white plays rook eight three and
and then moves over
to a2 he will not win the pawn oh he's
gonna play it out
but now he's playing the ball he's gonna
go for the he's gonna go for the
for the flag that's all that razor does
he knows this is a drawn position he
knows he can't really make any progress
we're going to go for the flag but but
he's lost black is lost in this position
white is winning this position no
doubt about it i don't know why i didn't
play king g5 there but this is a winning
position
for white this is over okay moving the
king back and forth
was not six seconds ago eight seconds
piece is back he's missed the technique
and bought his pieces back but he's
still winning oh he dropped the rook
look the rook andrew and ferocia
let me go real quick i know we have a
lot of games going on but i want to show
real quick something on move 30 that we
all missed
why was this a blunder
it wasn't taking the queen there was
something else oh can you take on a4
we take on a four yeah and then we need
a bishop
that's the one gg ggo as they would say
quickly and missed that tactic nakamura
only one point up by the way now
there this key holding the one point gap
well this one is also only one point gap
we have some very exciting matches going
on very competitive indeed this is what
we expect to see
in the finals and here we have
this game this is farouza versus andrew
tang
andrew needs another win somehow
another win and i'm liking this position
for white i'm like oh
you have to play g5 that is coming in
lee the f5 square is going to be forever
the h5 square your bishop is terrible
this is awful and a sack on g5 let's go
opening up the position you couldn't
take that piece or you'd be crushed and
now it's
it's even horrible here you're getting
roasted on the squares
oh my goodness here comes a rook and the
rooks are going to double
on the h line and rookie sixth threat
check is threatened
you could just take because you cannot
take the knight oh it's the main one
on a stick
the sacrifices all black pieces were on
the other side of the board
you're at the wrong party buddy you need
to be over there to get it going
let's look at daniel versus darren ditki
real quick uh he carver just won his
game it's up two points seems like both
are trying to get a two-point edge
only three minutes left i think we got
our winners must win
no must-win game right now for the for
for andrew
and dania it's not over yet it's not
over yet
right now i mean it's basically over but
they have
a that's a good position for the
last win game daniel has to win this
game
in a position where he's down upon he's
got to win this game
okay just got the pawn back that's good
got to figure out how to win
and and hikaru now defending like a
beast
but look at that up up coupon up two
pawns
it's gotta be i donated the pawn on two
still with a little bit of chance after
f5 swing the rook and now a check and
now he's up upon again
will he be able to maintain the pawn
though that knight on g7 does not
promise much
and ikaro's pieces are more active yeah
he's gonna drag this out he's will drag
this out
he just took the pawn and now he's ready
for mother
he's great for a blunder it's a mate
threat
got to play h4 and there's a pin so he
got to get out of the pin
saw that coming and now can he find a
trick does danya he needs a trick
of some kind but the clock is clock
times are my favorite
it's terrible i mean awful then he just
oh he's gonna lose that as well he needs
he needs a miracle
we need a christmas miracle right now or
darn is going to go oh yeah
34. yeah thanks for watching
oh my goodness they're going too bad now
he just pulled the rook
oh no the match is over the match
is over let's quickly look at this one
real quick
that hurt this is a must win for andrew
and the position
says no down three pawns uh the clock
times alireza
just needs to giddy up and this should
be easily done
okay but he should try to win because
right now he's just trying to play fast
i think you should try to win
it's easy for him to push his pawns just
push yeah there should be an easy win
technique there we go he's pushing four
seconds ago four seconds this could be
anything
three seconds left three seconds he's
going but you know what it doesn't
matter a draw wins it for him
a draw he just cannot lose win trade the
rooks take the rules oh
even if he doesn't win wins for him and
he does win the game on time
match is over he's through as is
nakamura it looks like nakamura
has done the do as well we have our two
finalists
it's going to be ikaru nakamura and ala
raza for ruja
upsetting andrew tang at least on the
bullet side he's much stronger
in regular classical chess but on the
bullet side he's not as highly rated
he's done it what he's supposed to do by
showing he's a better chess player
what a game man a lot of games from both
they both perform extremely all of them
have like 3400 bullet rating that is
insane to have here on chess.com
and we hear the thing it is over we have
hikaru
versus ferocious as the final which is
going to be
a great funnel uh as the players just
play it out
uh for the last but down here ditschy
and andrew tang pick up a nice thousand
dollars so
not a bad move for just a few few
minutes of chess
yeah how can you complain i mean this
this was really good and we get a final
a dream final
for ruja versus nakamura in the finals
that's a great that's a dream final
if it's bullet if it's classical if it's
rapid if it's
in chess 960 i don't care if it was
knots and crosses
this is a dream final to just have those
two amazing competitors two geniuses
play against each other so that's
definitely going to be a lot of fun
right now andrew tang looks like he's
about to pick up a game
where just going to be irrelevant as
he's winning the night on e4
but nobody cares uh there's no
consolation prize for winning the last
game after you lost the match
and so this is over yeah
this is going to be over uh probably
it's going to be a draw now because
these things have yeah
yeah the razer actually has come back
and now it doesn't look like there's any
wind oh
there we go so when eventually uh uh
he's played g4
this is this is uh not actually oh
no no chance no chance no it should be
it should be drawn i think
he wants to win there's sir dominance uh
but
this should be enough no the pawn is
going to fall and it is a draw we have
our finalists
we have nakamura versus ali raza
ferocia the iranian wonder kids it's
gonna be a really good one
it is it is it's it's going to be
uh a hot matchup but
hikaru we we knew he was a beast
andrew showed he could get close but not
enough against a
player of for rouge's ability
level what you saw there was just great
chess
ability now we we have this i'm not
going to make up a word
bullet ability right you you could have
strong
bullet ability but when i combine the
speed
with the strength of the moves then you
get people like hikaru you get people
like
ali raza i'm sure andrew tank spanks
most people when he's sitting in front
of them with his speed and he
intimidates them
but when he's got to see good moves kind
of coming at him some strong
27 50 moves that alareza dropped on him
what about this what about this answer
this question
you can play as fast as you like 30
seconds in i got the better opening i
got the better middle game
i got the better end game technique oh
you're playing really fast but i got the
winning position with 20 seconds left
i can handle myself that's what he faced
it was too much of a heavyweight battle
for him to handle
and that was it i'll erase this through
i'll raise this through we have one more
game and we will interview the winner
or the winner and loser i'm not quite
sure we're gonna see probably just the
winner so
we'll see what's gonna go up we're gonna
go on the final quick break we're not
gonna say final quick wait we're all
going on a quick break
and we'll be back with the final it's
going so fast maurice with the final
of the bold open chess championship see
you guys in just a bit
[Music]
and we are back for the final match
ladies and gentlemen hikaru nakamura
will be playing alibrazier for russia
let's just jump
right in to the scene that has them
here we go we got ikara nakamura and
eraser
racer looking a bit he's looking chill
they're both looking chill
they're both looking good they are ready
to party
yes and alireza just needs to figure out
the whole camera thing
obviously hikaru is probably in a tsm
studio
right now so he's got the whole set up
so everything looks clean and nice
alireza has us in the interrogation room
this is when you've committed a crime
and they've got the lights on you in it
and alireza's looking at you and saying
just confess just confess it it'll be
easier on you if you just confess
so he's got he's got to get a different
look for sure
but it doesn't matter because he's got
the moves indeed he got the moves like
jagger
we will see if he can get it done and
many people are saying
this is a future world champion we're
looking at this is a future world
champion
he's going to be playing magnus maybe in
four or five years
but right now hikar was saying but it's
today it's today exactly future
is not now okay let's get it done
and the man right now in bullet
is clearly hikaru nakamura i do like uh
that idea that if eli razor wins we'll
interview him as the good cop bad cop
uh maurice i think that's a brilliant
idea that we got going on with the
lights uh
but the games are about to start no
scratch that the games
have started hikaru not starting with b3
uh i am perplexed
let me tell you he knows he's playing
it's a very good player he can't mess
around
at all and there's going to be some
preparation on the part of alareza
because he's
guessing that he's playing against
nakamura remember they've played before
they play on the magnus carlsen tour
they
know each other they he knows how strong
ali raza is does nakamura so he's not
going to mess around
against this young g so we are going to
see some good
chess and already we're seeing a kind of
technical type
positions appear on the board as hikaru
is
worse here no question about it black
has a beautiful bishop
in comparison and the dominant on the c
line but here goes b3
smart move this is going to make the
game a lot easier to defend
for white and that's the great thing
about hikaru is his defensive skills but
i didn't like what
alareza just did right there he left the
c file
he refused to give up his advantage and
left the c file
oh he lost the bishop blundered me
just blundered mate you see there he
really didn't want to concede
the win because he didn't want to give
him the c file it just didn't think it
was enough
and he gave nakamura the c file and it
bit him on the rear end
at the end of the game unbelievable that
is detrimental especially from a very
that's the thing with nakamura it's like
a very stable position there is no
action
bam he's on to you give me your palms
worse than that i call nakamura hydra
you try to chop off one head in the
position
and two more grow he's simply he's just
astonishing defender he is so tenacious
when he's losing and the worst part is
he's
thinking about winning when he's losing
he's thinking about winning the game he
doesn't want to give you a draw
he's going to defend like a beast and
then he's going to come back
and he's going to win the game and then
he's going to demoralize you when he
does that look at this position again
ali raza out playing in nakamura
beautiful position someone got a sack on
g6
he's got a second g6 100 begging to
happen look at the dark square
domination
this position is ugly i mean fugly
is another word you could use there i
won't describe for you what that means
how does he break through ali race is
trying to figure it out he wants a sack
he's going to take him
h5 he could take on g6
the pin was on oh my goodness he missed
it
and now he's definitely being able to
take on jesus take an h5
i can take an h5 okay take it on h5 look
at yourself something is dangerous on
the h line for white
how does he push through h5 and and some
kind of he could have called f6
it would have been over the moment again
there he goes and this is a mating
attack let's go this is winning
he better not lose this one this is the
queen of six
lock it up well no you're right
you're right over right would have done
that he would have made it his life easy
but now he's definitely no he's he's
made his life complicated
he's given up he's one of them oh that's
a nice move e60
he's up a full rook with eight seconds
on the clock
i don't care how fast nakamura is he's
not going to be able to
hold off in this position he's
definitely going to lose
can't make it there we go and then it's
back both
games he got outplayed nakamura but
there were some misses there for ali
raisin
got to get himself tight so that he
could take advantage of those
opportunities
that was very rare that we saw multiple
multiple misses
one after the other and body still won
so the
the way he played in the opening was
just so detrimental to
icarus play that he did win that game
but
now we're going to see here when you
mentioned hydra i thought you were a
marvel fans movie we're talking about
i'm not sure if you know that
my hydra is like the secret organization
we make uh
hikaru the antagonist we have razor the
protagonist
i'm a classical guy i'm a classical guy
you know i
i'm an english major we go back to the
classical
descriptions i you know you young g's
remember stuff like
like that or know stuff like that that i
don't know but there here we go
this is crushing right now for ikaru
this is the thing about him as well when
we say hydra all right
you beat him and you think i got him
look what i'm doing
i got hit car who he's messing up guess
what you're resigning the next game
that's what's happening
that's how he is he doesn't get frazzled
he could go down two
and he's gonna win five i mean that's
just the nature of this beast
and interestingly we have seen the same
opening three times in a row now from
both ends
so let's see what's going to happen
again yeah there's going to be an attack
on the king side
i'm not sure if i specifically liked it
but ikaro probably
found out where the flaw was and he's
going to defend it properly this time
yeah the problem was he took on e5 and a
lot of complete domination after the
pawn took
and caused a dark square weaknesses
permanently in his position
this is not so rosy either by the way
he's got a weakness on e6
and alireza is going to pound at it he's
going to double on the d
the e line and eventually he's going to
play for the move
d5 so nakamura has to be watchful and
also by the way the move h5 is going to
come
at the right moment and that's going to
cause some challenges as well
so here this is an interesting exchange
of pawns
i didn't like the trade of queens i
would have kept the pieces on the board
and but the knight on f3 is really well
placed i would have liked to play g5 as
well but still
this position is looking okay for
white i'm like white with the looks
double on the seventh
that was really good for right ninety
five oh he could have won the pc
these games that you're supposed to win
he missed a straight win of a piece but
his h pawn is talking
his h pawn is barking right now so
that's a challenge for nakamura nakamura
has decided to get rid of it oh he's
trying to play
this position where he's down a knight
but he's got some a passer
this is winning though why the f i'm
about to say why aren't you pushing your
f pawn
just push him uh defend that and the
knight will be able to go to the f57
push it again push it again just push it
again this is easy
and now it's all about stopping the play
for
black but it was a sneaky trick
one little trick queen on the board ali
raza bouncing back we have a wow
going on right now folks this is good
two to two
let's go two and a half minutes left on
the clock i don't care who wins but i
want a sudden death
maurice i want to jump out of my chair i
want to jump in and out of my chair for
something happening let's go i'm going
to tell you that white has won every
game so far
why that's true every single game all
right
this is just hitting hit and hit back
hit and hit back that's how
we like the heavyweight matches but
somebody has to save the position with
black
and alert has played this variation
where it looked like he was dropping a
pawn but he got it right back in the
sicilian there's a good position
for black a great position for black so
he just needs to keep it equal i don't
like that move queen beat though
and the threats are on and now the queen
side is collapsing
oh what's your favorite rook oh bishop
of free bishop f3
nasty and you're losing a piece that was
not well played by the youngster there
the bet the retreating moves is kind of
crowding in on his own self
and white wins yet again nakamura is up
again
i mean i get uh raising knows i'm black
so i'm gonna lose anyway
might as well grab the white pieces and
uh and punch through that way so let's
see how that's gonna go
out uh f4 or five designation but the
way he played that with
his last position was just unacceptable
it was unacceptable
that you just can't do that you just
can't do that and now knight g4 with the
knight landing on e3 c2 is hanging
and he's got to take on f5 just do it
like g4
okay okay he is he won
material but it's not very spicy what do
we have here
f6 nakamura allowed f6
and suddenly he's sitting up in his
chair realizing that his
that side of the board is collapsing uh
do you take it good question no we move
this king over and g5 rook g1 is what
he's hoping for but the king's going to
escape to h5
wait what is this you getting out h4 go
for h6
oh that would have been that would have
been something yeah you're right
but knight g5 crash boom he's through
he's gonna
let's go this is a mating attack for
real
this is good stuff right now but
nakamura has to keep his cool
he's taken and he's and he's running
he's on his high horse and everybody's
dropping look at all those pros
he could take on he could take on d5
with check and the problem is
now he has no attack he's got to turn
the game around he's just
giving up his bishop and he's giving
what's going on here
but he couldn't figure out what to do
and he
lost the game the first loss for white
in the match
nakamura takes it with the black pieces
that was nasty that steal
that was nasty that is nasty and we will
see
a lot of stalling this time because we
only have five and a half minutes left
maurice
and a two point gap which means carl's
gonna take things slow if he's in the
losing position
that that was a big time win let me tell
you
big time win for hikaru to get a game
where he was just lost
he was just simply lost and
now farouza is in a must-win situation
i'm going to tell it to you right now
farouza must win this game and it's not
looking good for him
he must win this game if he doesn't win
this game the match is over
that's my bet if he doesn't win this
game the match is simply over and i
think that last
loss may be the decider but he must win
this game
in front of us right now and he has his
chances great night on c4
but he's got to figure it out because
the pawn the knight on d4 is also quite
strong
so not easy to hold or to try to get any
chances maggie two
free pawn no it's not it's not i mean
what is this move
definitely one knight f1 check idea
there was a
there's a queenie one but naka is trying
to make sure there's a queen deal and he
noticed what to do
all right now now he gets at least a
draw but he hasn't
but he doesn't and now nakamura playing
check you got to move over
naka is just torturing him now because
he can't figure out
wait a minute is it what do we have it
looks like both of them are losing
it looks like both of them are losing i
couldn't know but i know
ellie raises losing on time he's gonna
move fast he has only seven seconds left
but that bla
that white king looks terrible but how
do you get at it this is not gonna be
the way to get at it
nope that didn't do it and he's now
officially losing
the match he's going to lose the match
this is over
he is totally dead and that game he lost
the last game
was the decider because look at the car
he's bumping he's going let's go yeah
he's feeling it now he knows the match
is over
that was a big win it's only three
minutes left so essentially only two
games remaining
ali raza could not have afforded to lose
that last
not this game that just passed but the
one before it because that cost
him this game as well and now he's in
deep trouble he's not going to be able
to win
fast enough and he's going for it he's
just going for it with this move he's
just saying
i'm just going to go for it i'm giving
up a rook it doesn't matter i just want
to get some kind of attack going and try
to win quickly
knocker could sit here for a while he's
played a very risky
move in g5 and his kick wow look at that
king he's uh
he's tackling g5 here bishop takes g5
and knight he's
95 was not the one was not
what about bishop g6 there if he took
him
now the guy's gonna have enough time uh
queen f8 was coming
this is over this is over the match is
over he car is gonna win
this match we're we're just looking to
see whether or not
farouja can somehow
win a game and keep it respectable but
now d5 on the board and naca
is feeling himself absolutely he's up a
whole rook with
no attack to speak on nothing here it is
all black
black to win he's going to win this game
there is a resignation in
and the route is on hikaru nakamura
as predicted showing why he's the best
in the world
absolutely there was a i think about
bishop g6 that would have been a cute
tactic but
let's keep on this game as it is there's
only two look at him
he's going bananas you don't know what
he takes but i want some of that as well
he's the number one street chess
streamer
in the world he's also one of the
greatest competitors we've ever seen
look at this
look at what he's just done queen got
attacked and he look at him he's
partying now
he's partying he's playing to the crowd
he's playing to the crowd he has his
fans
and look at him he's waving it up i mean
he may not be able to dance
but he's dancing all over perugia right
now
i mean he's like yo yo what's up what's
up i am killing this youngster
you you're maybe the future son but i'm
the president
and i'm going to show you how it's done
and look at him
partying like it's 1999 1999 just about
to say
perfect yeah just enjoying this advent
major edge in this position just winning
now to bring the king over
and it's going to be over look at that
g3 technique
your king is stuck just move your king
back and forth my king is coming over
here right now
he can do that there's nothing he can do
the king's just coming over then the
king's coming up
then the king's going up some more uh
well
you can't draw you can't afford to draw
the game that's that's that's definitely
resignation
so in cairo just playing it out taking a
look
i'm not sure exactly how he wins though
there must be a winning
idea here what is wow
do you know how you could have won you
know how you should have won
i should do well he should have played
king a3 after before check that was the
thing remember
before checking play king a3
and then his king just marches up the
board that's what he should have done so
he can't
miss that idea at the end there but you
know what
he's not missed much today he's up four
games with only
20 seconds left folks it's the party
hour for hikaru as he's gonna be able to
stream
he's streaming now but he's all his fans
are watching him prove
why he's so dominant this is why they
love him because he just gets it done
when it's time to get it done
absolutely he knew it was time to boogie
and he's showing that as well with g4
very aggressive rook only move rook
takes d3
yeah seems like the only move and yes
and good only and good is there a way to
to
just figure you know just when you think
you might have a power rule
he says you can have whatever you like
go ahead take whatever you like
we're ju and now a sacrifice okay that
looks like a good sack
you might have to take it and play
bishop g7
uh that looks like uh not a first mate
as he's allowed and now fuji six queen
g6
knight is even sexier i like it i like
it sexier
that would have been nice no queen g6 is
real g5
queen g6 is rook g5 excuse me you retray
it off and then it's still queen
96 mate no because there's a pawn on f7
oh you're correct you're right no you're
right you have to try to win material
with knight g6
and then take oh he still doesn't though
did he think
we were busy talking about it
the rook left that's what happened the
rook left f5 and went to f4
and he got it but naka is like so what
i'm i won three congratulations for the
most spectacular move
of the match but i'll take the 10k
that's what he says congrats on your
move i'll take the 5k
that's for me we're going to get him on
interview so we're going to go on a
really short break chat don't go
anywhere we'll be back
with grand master hikaru nakamura see
you guys just a bit
[Music]
so
and welcome back everyone to the bullet
open championship we
are here in the presence of legends uh
was already maurice actually now also he
coroner kimura
and alaris of russia uh hikaru i saw you
were dancing
how are you feeling i mean it it was
just a very ten it was very tense and
actually i thought i mean
when i won a couple of games it was nice
to relax the end
so um yeah it was a tough match but i
found a way so i'm pretty happy
alareza it looked like you had a good
chance
in the very beginning and you're sorry
in the opening game we were doing well
and
it looks like hikaru stole that game you
were able to bounce back once
and then it was back and forth
heavyweight action what was your feeling
do you think that you you could have
possibly taken the lead early
and did that disturb you at all when he
was able to play such masterful defense
to stop you yeah i mean when
we played the first four games i
understood my black openings are just
awful in this match
so i knew that i should play very good
with white
and i really didn't know how to like
improve it so that was the main problem
i think and
yeah okay that game that i didn't win it
was it was a good defense of course by
color but
in general i think um the black opening
was my problem
yeah we noticed that i think white
formed five times in a row
white was definitely the favorites to uh
to go in ikaru
uh you had a very good start uh some
hard opposition how do you feel about
your first games going against uh
danielski
i mean i think basically because the the
format was so short with 15 minutes like
at the very start
i mean it's super critical the first
probably two games decide i think most
matches um and yeah i thought against
dania
um it was very very tense with some back
and forth also
um but i think the most important thing
is that i didn't lose a game like the
first game in any of the match i think
that actually was was very very
important because it was always
uh like especially the final match i
would win a game then ollie russell
would win and i would win so it was
always it was always after my win he
would have to win again with white and i
think it's very hard when you have to
keep winning um
winning every game with white especially
what do you need to do you think alyreza
given this challenge
it seems like nakamura always rises to
the occasion just
just rising rising especially in bullet
looks like everybody on the planet
is terrified when naka is sitting across
from them
in bullet what do you need to do to
break this spell
to make it seem like somebody can beat
this guy
of course hikaru has a very good
experience i learned a lot from him
when i played bullets so
i i still expect that then i could have
done better but
like me losing to a car is nothing like
um some crazy things so
and of course i think i could improve
more in bullets
when i could maybe a little older but
now
i think i played my like on the best
today so
absolutely uh for roger you played
extraordinary today it was a very tense
match against
uh was andrew again or jeffrey shung i
think you played entertain there
uh very tense match anyway uh i'm out of
questions maurice
you want to shoot one absolutely i want
to congratulate ricardo once again
i mean you were my pick to win this
whole thing you delivered
once more you're feeling as you're
streaming
and playing bullet you're talking you
look like you're having so much fun
is that the truth you're having such a
good time doing all this you look like
you're on top of the world right now
yeah i mean i think it's it's a lot of
fun when you can play i mean i think the
fact that there's so many people who are
watching chess whether it's my channel
whether it's chess.com channel um
that that certainly uh gives me a lot of
motivation i really do enjoy it so
i mean it's all about the fans i mean
they're the reason that we play at least
online for sure so
i'm just grateful there's so many people
who love the game of chess that's really
what it comes down to and that that
really does give me the motivation i
think more than anything else
well keep doing what you do great job
great work
and alareza we know you're the future
you say a little older i'm thinking
a little older like six months because
you're growing before our eyes
congratulations to you both for making
it this far
and finally again congrats to karu for
having a spectacular result
thank you you guys have a good thank you
yeah thank you guys we're going to hit
you with the raid after this again hikar
congratulations alireza
let's hope you start a stream as well i
know you're on twitch so we might as
well get some
bullet matches late night on the twitch
stream as well so thank you guys so much
for being here and have a have a great
stream
see you guys thank you all right
let's look at the final bracket for the
final time he did have a
tough start against andrew tang ali
razor but he did come back
really really well i went five and a
half two and a half and
it's always ten steffi caro there
because he's such a legend maurice and
uh that was that was a good match nice
ending match went back and forth we had
some jobs
we had some bug we had some gangsters in
the position especially when we had that
king side attack um that was a great
event
well it all came down to that one game
i think it was game six where ali raza
was hunting with the white pieces trying
to even up again
as nakamura said it's hard when you
get hit you hit back he hits you again
you hit back and he hits you again
there's three times you got hit
the pressure's on you must deliver in
that next game
and unfortunately he was winning he was
winning but
how many times have we heard that
against hikaru nakamura ikaru stole that
game and once he grabbed that game and
took a two-point lead
that was it that was all she wrote
icarus shows why he is such a beast
in these competitions at bullet chess
and he's having a good time
and like i said to him it's lovely it's
amazing what he's doing for chess
with his streams people following in a
big way people
loving it certainly just forging ahead
for those of us who stream like myself i
just came into this streaming world
in in october i mean maybe september
october
so i'm still at the very beginning but
hikaru is somebody we all look up to
is getting it done showing what chess
can do he's powering ahead and he's
doing it not only
with with flash he's doing it because
he's a champion
exactly and i think what the one thing
i've learned today maurice is
when the chorus starts dancing you know
it's over
you know it's done it's over it's over
it's over all right so we're going to
raise
carl make sure to follow maurice astley
twitch.the v slash game ashley you can
see it under here he streams at
5 00 p.m eastern time tomorrow
am i correct that's right around that
time let's
give her more or less or less i'll be
preparing a lot of good stuff
for tomorrow so you know my streams are
all about instruction i want
fans to learn not just be entertained
but to learn
some stuff about chess i always bring
some new ideas
to the table of course there's also the
gangsters gangsta chess edition we got
that segment of the show
so you're gonna see some good chess
somebody's gonna get hurt uh in
the games always bring that fire as well
so we're
we're gonna have some fun tomorrow
absolutely and there's no
instructional might on my end of the
stream but there is a puppy
you see my puppy maurice that is a
reason to follow you gotta keep too sure
she's cute
royce it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much you've been amazing at
this commentary
and you'll be back here anytime i know
that i'll probably be behind doing the
production so
former race ashley this is about too big
and we're gonna hit the caro
and thank you guys so much for watching
make sure to follow us especially
maurice
and we will see you in the next event
good night everyone
[Music]
you